want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carl michael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
too you have michael jordan level genius
at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn how to control
your mind in minutes with joe dispenza
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one break your old habits
we have a huge frontal lobe and it's 40
of our entire brain
and most people uh when they have a
thought they just think that that's the
truth
and i think one of my greatest
realizations in my own journey was
just because you have a thought doesn't
necessarily mean it's true
so if you think sixty to seventy
thousand thoughts in one day and we do
and ninety percent of those thoughts are
the same thoughts as the day before and
you believe that your thoughts have
something to do with your destiny
your life's not going to change very
much because the same thought leads to
the same choice the same choice leads to
the same behavior
the same behavior creates the same
experience and the same experience
produces the same emotion
and so then the act of becoming
conscious
of this process to to begin to become
more aware
of how you think how you act and how you
feel it's called metacognition
and so then why is that important
because the more
conscious you become of those
unconscious states of mind and body
the less likely you're going to go
unconscious during the day and that
thought
is not going to slip by your awareness
unchecked
because you're it means to know thyself
and the word meditation means to become
familiar with
so as you become familiar with the
thoughts the behaviors and emotions of
the old self
you're retiring that old self as you
fire and wire new thoughts and condition
the body into a new emotional state
if you do that enough times it'll begin
to become familiar to you so
it's so important uh just like a garden
if you're planting a garden you got to
get rid of the weeds
you got to take the plants from the past
year and you got to pull them out
the rocks that sift to the top that are
like our emotional blocks they have to
be removed the soil has to be tenderized
and broken down we have to
we have to make room to plant a new
garden so primarily
we learn the most about ourselves and
others when we're uncomfortable
because the moment you move into that
uncomfortable state normally a program
jumps in when that program jumps in it's
because a person doesn't want to be in
the present moment
and engage it consciously so when you
teach people how to do that
with a meditative process it turns out
that when they're in their life
they're less likely to emotionally react
they're less likely to be so rigid and
believe the thoughts they were thinking
they're more aware of when they go
unconscious back into a habit and that
is what starts the process of change
and so we have to unlearn before we
relearn we have to break the habit of
the old self before we reinvent the new
self we have to
prune synaptic connections and sprout
new connections we have to
unfire and unwire and re-fire and rewire
we have to unmemorize emotions that are
stored in the body
then recondition the body to a new mind
into a new motion like deprogram and
reprogram
that's the act and it's a two-step
process yeah i like the way that you
call that out as an action there was
another thing that you said that i
thought was really powerful
about how insights themselves are
essentially inert they don't do
anything um what what then do we do with
an insight how do we take a breakthrough
moment and make sure that it's not
just a breakthrough moment like i
guarantee people watching right now are
having like 100 aha moments
for sure that was definitely the case
for me as i was researching you and when
you
said that i was like and that's the
danger that you have the aha and then
nothing yeah
yeah and that's it's a it is a danger
because then people will
will shrink back into mediocracy and
they'll use the insight to excuse them
from taking a leap
they'll say yeah you know i have a
chemical imbalance in my brain yeah my
father
was really overbearing he was a
perfectionist that's why i am the way i
am you know people
they come up with stuff to to excuse
themselves the insight
is actually giving them permission to
stay
limited and it's it's an amazing idea
because
they'll say to you that they really want
to get over their anxiety
but let's okay let's take your
ex-husband let's put him in a
straitjacket
let's duct tape him and shoot him to the
moon now what i mean what are you going
to do now you still
have to make those changes and so when
the person's enemy dies or
something shifts in their life and that
person's gone they'll find another
person to hate
this is just how we function as human
beings we just slide another
reason to feel those emotions so i think
i think when people start to understand
this you know
i think knowledge is power but knowledge
about yourself is self-empowerment
rule number two hardwire your brain i
believe in
human possibility human potential and i
think that
one of our biggest limiting beliefs is
the belief
have how limited we really are and so my
interest is to give people
the science to begin to understand how
powerful they really are
and i think that science really is the
language that does that really
well and and the new sciences like
quantum physics and
neuroplasticity neuroscience
neuroendocrinology you know
psychoneuroimmunology the mind body
connection epigenetics all
of those sciences point the finger at
possibilities so
i want to create a language for people
from a philosophical or theoretical
standpoint for them to begin to
understand what's possible
but then i want to be able to have those
people begin to wire that information
in their brain completely because
learning is making new connections right
in the brain
but remembering is maintaining and
sustaining those connections and it's so
much
easier to lose our vision than to
remember it right so then
we have to begin to hardwire the brain
or install the neurological hardware
in preparation for an experience so the
more people understand what they're
doing and why
then the how gets easier so i want to
then set up the conditions
in an environment in a in a workshop
where people can begin to
apply or personalize what they learn so
that they can have an experience an
experience then further enriches the
brain but
the prize of an experience is an emotion
and once you start
feeling unlimited once you start feeling
abundant once you start feeling worthy
now you're teaching your body chemically
to understand what your mind is
intellectually understood so
knowledge is for the mind and
experiences for the body and people
begin to embody the truth
of that philosophy now if they can
repeat it over and over again
it'll become innate in them and become
natural second nature
become easier they begin to master that
philosophy so
i want people to begin to understand
that
thoughts are very powerful feelings
drive our thoughts
and that they can begin to create a
better life for themselves once they
understand some of these principles
rule number three become supernatural i
think
we're living in such an amazing time
right now
i mean if you are not being challenged
in some way in your life you're not
alive
and all of this is an initiation
and i don't believe that you have to go
to any school of ancient wisdom perched
in the himalayas
or for information or training any
longer if you see your
life as the school as the initiation
then you can no longer be a victim to
your life you're going to have to meet
the challenges
in your life from a greater level of
mind greater than the mind that created
it
and so there have been plenty of
peer-reviewed articles on the power of
peace gathering
projects lower crime that lower trauma
incidences of
of uh death and economic growth it's all
related to what's happening right now
for us
and it's not enough though for us to
just focus on peace
and expect the world to change because
in the peace gathering projects when the
event was over
a lot of the crime and violence returned
back to its ceiling level again
it's more important for us not only to
embody that piece and feel it but then
to demonstrate it
and when we begin to demonstrate it i
think we give
people permission to do the same that
means that we can't be
preaching peace and then be stuck in
traffic and you know
flipping people off or you know or
arguing with your co-worker you don't
get to stand up for peace if you have
conflict in your life
so when we start i believe start that
self-contemplative process of looking
within
and instead of judging someone or
something look to see if there's an
aspect of ourselves
within that person or when that
situation that we may need to change and
if we're all doing that at the same time
something greater greater consciousness
is going to emerge
and so i believe that it should never be
about a person
it should be about principles and when
we stand up for principles that creates
community
because you could be one belief or
another belief but if you're
sharing the same principles with your
joy and freedom
and cooperation and connection that's
what builds communities
so then everything in our world right
now
is reminding us of separation whether
it's war
whether it's violence whether it's
political deceit
whether it's prejudice all of those
things cause us to live by the stress
hormones
and when we're living in that state of
survival we're not trusting
and we become more selfish so then
starting our day asking ourselves what
would be the greatest
expression of myself i'd like to present
to the world
and then making the choice to not get up
until we are that person
i think that begins to demonstrate
greatness
and when there is adversity and when
there are challenges in our life
the question of course becomes how do we
become
supernatural and that means we're going
to have to do what feels
unnatural at first when everybody else
is in poverty and lack that's the time
to give
when everybody else is in fear and
vigilance that's the time to show
courage
when people are angry and hating and
prejudice that's the time to show
compassion
people are competing to rush to get to
the top that's the time to change your
energy and draw the experience to you
and if you keep doing what's unnatural
over and over again
sooner or later you're going to become
supernatural also if you want to build
more confidence the sign says it can
take up to
254 days of consecutive action to
successfully
build a habit so i've created a free
program for you where every day
for 254 days i will send you an unlisted
video to your email
absolutely free to help you build your
confidence the link to join is in the
description below
you were up and dressed and ready to go
before your parents were up
you know why because you knew something
unexpected was gonna happen
that's how we should live our lives
waking up with the understanding
to expect the unexpected rule number
four balance your nervous system
think of your autonomic nervous system
as
the automatic nervous system and i've
been saying for years that
autonomic is synonymous with automatic
and it's that
part of our systems part of our nervous
system
that functions behind the scenes of our
awareness and it regulates
body temperature and and hormones and
blood supply and blood sugar levels
in it and it happens without any uh of
our conscious mind
so in the autonomic nervous system there
are two branches so
one is the sympathetic nervous system
and
its job is for protection
from threats and dangers in our outer
environment and think of the sympathetic
nervous system as the gas pedal
and when there's a danger to the gross
anatomy of the body
by something in our outer world that we
can perceive with our
senses this system is switched on
automatically and
once it turns on there's a host of
physiological functions
that begin to happen automatically and
when that occurs we're mobilizing all of
the body's energy
all of the body's resources uh for that
threat or that danger to deal with it
and
and when it's switched on uh we don't go
half
in we go all the way in because we have
to make sure that the body is going to
survive
survive in a threat or a danger in the
outer environment
and and when there's a release of all
those adrenal hormones
we're tapping the body's resources and
we're mobilizing all of its energy and
pupils dilate salivary juices shut off
respiratory rate increases heart rate
increases
blood is sent to the extremities glucose
is mobilized the immune system dials up
and then it dials down
and all of these systems switching on
and turning on
is to be able to allow the body to adapt
to some threat in the outer world and uh
that is the gas pedal and the
sympathetic nervous system or the
fight-or-flight nervous system
uh causes us to really do just a few
things to run
from the danger to fight and stay
or to freeze and hide and those are the
primary choices that we have
created in evolution and so
when the sympathetic nervous system is
switched on and
we as we've been saying for very long
for a very long time
the short-term effect of the hormones of
stress
the body can adapt and return back to
balance and it switches on
the other nervous system that branch of
the autonomic nervous system
called the parasympathetic nervous
system and think
of that nervous system as the break
or the clutch this is where the body
conserves energy this is where
utilizes nutrients and and transports
chemicals to cells and metabolism goes
up and and this is a time for growth
this is a time for repair
this is a time for restoration and
there's a delicate balance between the
sympathetic nervous system
and the parasympathetic nervous system
and so then
when you're feeling uh constant fear
when you're feeling constant anger or
aggression when you're feeling constant
pain and suffering
and you're living by the hormones of
stress what was once very adaptive is
now
very maladaptive because if stress is
knocking your brain and body out of
balance and the stress response is what
the body does to return it back to order
if we're living in constant fear then we
are tapping the body's vital resources
and there's no energy for growth repair
restoration there's no energy for
long-term building projects
and rule number five the last one before
very special bonus clip
is be comfortable in the unknown the
hardest part about
change is not making the same choice as
you did the day before
and the moment you decide to no longer
think the same way
make the same choice act the same way
create the same experience or live by
the same emotion
it's going to feel uncomfortable it's
going to feel
unfamiliar there is going to be a
certain amount of uncertainty
and unpredictability and the moment you
feel uncomfortable
you just stepped into the river of
change
now most people the moment they feel
uncomfortable they return back to the
familiar
state of the mind and body they start
thinking the same way acting the same
way
feeling the same way and they say this
feels right
no in fact that feels familiar now going
from the old self
to the new self is the neurological
is the chemical is the biological is the
hormonal and even genetic
death of the old self that void
that place of uncertainty that unknown
is the perfect place to create him and
if you and i can become
comfortable in that unknown and begin to
decide who we do want to be
in other words many people say when
they're in that unknown i can't predict
my future
this doesn't feel right well the best
way to predict your future
is to create it not in the known but in
the unknown
so what if you said now what thoughts
do i want to fire and wire in my brain
what behaviors do i want to demonstrate
and if you were to close your eyes and
begin to think about how you're going to
act
the mere act of mentally rehearsing who
you're going to be
begins to install the neurological
circuits in your brain
to look like the experience has already
occurred
now what that means is the brain is
primed
in its circuitry to no longer be living
in the past
but now living in the future if you want
to change your life
in the next 30 days for free check out
my training right here below or if you
want to know tony robbins exercises to
train your body and mind check out the
video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy them continue to believe
and i'll see you there